je me rappelle est parti europe allait
rejouer un ami dans un café puis je suis
jamais arrivé ou café que c'est juste le
prêt à sherbrooke quand je me suis
réveillé que là tranquillement mes
parents me raconter que ce texte
c'était pas mal grave ce que j'avais eue
j'ai voulu éviter un trou klaï avait une
voiture qui relaie rouler coller sur moi
puis à me frapper
puis après ce soit à me frapper par en
arrière mais je suis allé ce matin et a
frappé dans son pare brise
c'est comme voler par dessus l'auto qui
tombe en arrière de l'auto
parce qu'il me regarder dans un coma
artificiel et trois premiers jours je te
faisais intensifs puis il était comme
poste
certains des dommages qu'ils avaient été
causés au cerveau puis celui qu'elle
aime opéré au cerveau fait qu'il
préférait que je sois pour conscient au
clos de 6 à face ce soit - pays mais la
premier première semaine je me rappelle
de rien puis quand je me suis réveillé
j'étais hémiplégique la gauche pouvait
plus bouger puis vu que les médecins que
passer certains de simonet stamos et
j'étais capable de manger comme il faut
que je te paraître au 20 heures je peux
pas boire d'eau
mais parce que mais premièrement au
début je n'étais plus capable de marcher
petit stock on apprend à marcher on est
petit on n'a pas conscience de source
ça va tout seul on se lève sur mer mais
là à 23h et apprendre à marcher nos
gains l'offre était conscient et c'est
toi qui décide quoi tu commences ou
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
je compris notre vie comme plus l'heure
où loeb c'est frustrant parce que tu
savais qu'au début oui je marchais avec
le faux sur comment aux pays pauvres
ce taureau des fois c'est dur sur les
goûts maintenant puis c'est la même
chose ici avec juste la mémoire a été
affecté aussi de retenir des no ça prend
des nouveaux trucs là quand j'arrive à
une nouvelle place toutes les gens ce
trésor bonjour bonjour oui ok c'est bon
je tais le nom jean m'a rappelé avec
milieu mais après je vais revoir la
personne je me rappelle vitesse de
traitement de l'information comme ça
j'ai besoin d'un peu plus de
concentration la carrière trop brutaux
ou trop de monde qui me parlent en même
temps d'être capable de gérer comme la
même la même manière qu'à bas puis je
suis fatigué un peu plus s'il était à 20
je pouvais me couchais tard
ça peut voir facile
c'est sûr que je le sais que tout est
décalé j'aurais envie d'avoir une maison
au lieu d'être autonome de faire tout
d'abord raid jamais et je te peu retardé
à cause de ça et puis merci paul je
prends les choses au jour le jour ça
c'est je m'adapte aux choses qui
arrivent